[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody it's tuesday yep
and
we went ahead we pulled the trigger
we watched exorcist two the heretic yeah
and we paid for it yeah i mentioned it
the other day
and my buddy brian
that i went to the academy with he's a
dude that works on all those movies you
know worked on uh
was it vfw and bone tomahawk and
everything you know working on that new
movie about [ __ ] terror on the
prairie
but he's like no man i heard you
mentioning
exorcist two says go back and see it
it's a good movie i think it's better
than three actually that's what he said
he says it's kind of that's just crazy
he said well he said
[Laughter]
he said it's not a perfect movie all
right but he says it's a guilty of
pleasure of his it's just kind of like
an action-packed
movie you know and and i got a
do the renters and [ __ ]
and and i gotta [ __ ] agree with him i
i didn't i've seen it before but i guess
i didn't pay attention to it i'm not
sure i got through the first hour of it
or so
sometimes an old movie i really won't
pay much attention to if jenny's
watching it and i think jenny watched it
before yeah i've seen it a couple of
times and i was probably doing something
else at the time and just went yeah and
just moved on you know
but uh
watching it and paying attention to it
yeah i liked it
of course it was [ __ ] crazy
um but there there's a lot of good
things about it it's got a lot of cool
miniatures uh all-star cast james earl
jones is in it he's being kind of like
locust doom
locust style
yeah um there's all kinds of just oh my
god that would be an awesome shirt like
james earl jones with that locust that
look that head on yeah it says salsa
doom locust style on yeah yeah like that
i would wear that
and uh
just ned babies in it
for like five seconds
well i mean as as
as high up as he was in the credits i
was expecting him to be in it more i've
seen it before but i couldn't really
remember it's weird because
this movie
is
batshit crazy but it's also like from a
concept standpoint the concept of it is
crazy yeah um and but
and like i don't know like people that
said it was like action-packed it's not
though i thought it was like
really dragged in spots you know what
i'm saying i i something was always
happening
they were in a constant fight with
pazuzu
pretty much
um
it's it's just the the italian
dino de laurentiis [ __ ] philosophy of
oh well you like that well here's more
of that he just took the the exorcist it
all right and tried to amp it up and
give you more of what was in the
exorcist
and that was a different way
in a different way you know i mean
there's airplane crashes in it [ __ ]
locust attacks well an almost airplane
yeah that's right uh people [ __ ]
falling off car crash
badass weird mountains in africa that
look like [ __ ] i don't know like
[ __ ]
mud falling out of craigslist in like a
really bad mountain falling down they're
falling off mountains and [ __ ] and
[ __ ]
uh people are getting possessed like
that i mean anybody can be possessed at
any at the drop of a hat i could be
pazuzi right now i mean seriously
all of a sudden yeah
yeah
it opens up the pretty good scene of an
exorcism and a [ __ ] girl burns
herself up gets possessed and burns
herself up it's creepy it needs to be
remastered
because the colors are looking a little
dull i think a remaster of this would
probably be really cool if anybody
wanted to like bother doing it this is
out on blu-ray though so obviously they
did do something with it then maybe i'm
sure it has a cult following because
every movie does i don't know if we saw
the blu-ray version but probably this
what we saw will be paid for off the
amazon prime yeah that's amazing
probably the same one you'd get on the
blu-ray what was it 299 299 it's worth
2.99
yeah i don't well like i said i wanted
to talk about it because
okay um
it's not as bad as i remember yeah but
it's still
pretty stupid it's got richard burton in
it man and i think he's sober maybe well
he's sober uh the cast and crew would
like to have a word no they said he was
drunk
not so much at the beginning of the
shoot but as it went on yeah i guess he
just couldn't take it anymore
well
and little linda blair is probably about
18 or 19. she's 17. 17. she was 17 when
she stopped 17. her character is
supposed to be 16. okay she says she's
she's older than she was in the first
one
and uh she's cute man you know and she's
just good in the movie and
they [ __ ] got her doing crazy [ __ ]
sometimes she's looking looking like a
little kid [ __ ] then the next thing
you know she's running around and damn
see through night gown on top of
skyscraper almost falling off and then
she gets possessed later on and she
comes at you like a damn porn star she's
looking all sexy flirting with you and
[ __ ] trying to seduce the damn priest
even though she's
[ __ ]
underage
matter
they didn't look at that i remember you
you remember how it was when we were
kids back then well i'll get into that
because there's all kind of crazy [ __ ]
going on behind the scenes of this um
you know so i'll get into that that
shit's not acceptable today you could
never do that but uh just the way
society was i remember [ __ ] when i
was
you know [ __ ] in in these times
these people were like hippies and [ __ ]
you know they
they didn't really
you'd see a 14 year old with a [ __ ]
20 year old or a 25 year old people
didn't even [ __ ] bat an eye
and you didn't give a [ __ ]
the dude from [ __ ] twisted sister his
[ __ ] wife lissette i think he met her
when she was 13 or 12.
i think he was about
19. he'd get in big trouble today
but she was the head of his [ __ ] fan
club
he was already [ __ ] famous i think
she was only 16 17.
it's just it was another time
yeah but yeah i will say that there's
[ __ ] going on behind the scenes where
even linda blair like reading in the
script yeah the [ __ ] that was supposed
to happen in the movie like between her
and the priest she's like absolutely not
i'm not doing that right so um yeah
richard is like damn
well no because
that wasn't what no but see this is what
happens but that you don't know like
what was going on behind the thing so
you say all this stuff all right um i
can't see all this what actually
happened was that
the only reason okay so originally when
they were going to do when they were
talking about doing a sequel which
obviously they were going to because the
first
exorcist made all the [ __ ] money and
was like a massive success right
now the first thing they were thinking
of doing they said oh we have a good
idea let's just do some cheap like three
or four million dollar movie
that uses a lot of unused footage from
the first one and we'll just have like
the same kind of thing like a priest and
he has to go and exercise somebody and
we'll just use all this footage that we
didn't use it'll be super cheap blah
blah blah
but then eventually they're like okay
well no let's do an original story
problem was
uh william peter blatty who wrote the
novel obviously and william freaking who
directed the first one were like
absolutely not um this it doesn't need a
sequel it's a self-contained story um
it's a dumb idea we don't want to be
involved and a lot of the actors didn't
want to be involved either ellen burston
pretty much said the same thing she was
just kind of like it doesn't need a
sequel uh i don't want to do it she said
they offered me a lot of money but i
said no absolutely not
linda blair actually didn't want to do
it either at first um you know she was
only 12 or 13 when they did the original
one and she was actually not going to
continue acting at that point she was
going to go to veterinary school
but then they approached her with the
script which isn't what the movie turned
out to be
but they approached her with the first
draft of the script and they said hey
richard burton's going to be in it and
she was a big fan of his um and she'd
always wanted to work with them she's
like okay i'll do it as long as you
don't make me wear the demon makeup and
they said okay that's fine
now she said that the original version
of the script was awesome
uh so but the problem was that it was
rewritten she remembers it being
rewritten like five times
while the [ __ ] was going on yeah
one of the things like while they were
on set her and richard burton actually
developed a sort of like you know
father-daughter sort of thing
so when she got to the point
the story i heard was that she was in
the trailer one day like getting the
makeup people came in
and said um some they rewrote some [ __ ]
in the script
so that you and richard burton have to
do this really
they didn't even like say what it was
but they said it's bad it's offensive
that was the word they used they said
it's offensive
um and she basically went to the
director and said absolutely not i'm not
doing it so they had to like tone it way
down and it's still even kind of creepy
nowadays and they said they were really
uncomfortable doing it she's like she's
like it was he was like my dad so it was
like really really creepy and he was
really creeped out by it too because
it's like it's like making out with my
daughter it's super weird and especially
like i said it was supposed to be like
way worse so i don't know if they were
going full-on into like the into rape or
something like that but that's kind of
what it sounds like and linda blair said
absolutely not i'm not doing that
because you know she's like like i said
it's like with my dad and we're like
friends and stuff and that would be
really good louie chimes in reminds
everybody that elvis that elvis when
elvis met priscilla she was like third
like 14
14 or 15. and he was in the army at the
time that was his commanding officer's
daughter
which
people think this 18 year old thing that
was a federal that's that's kind of a
new concept that was a federal law about
uh photographing
kids like
pornography you had to be 18 to be in
any kind of
nude photography
but the state each state law had its own
different law about what the age of
consent was
so you could have sex with somebody
under the ajt
uh depending on what state you're in i
think mississippi the age of consent was
like 13 or 14 and it probably still is
it's just
nobody's ever changed if they changed it
maybe they've changed it recently or
they some
states added statutory laws like
if they're under the age of 18 you can't
be any more than four years older than
them or five years older than that kind
of [ __ ]
but that wasn't around in [ __ ] back
in the 70s
they did they
they were all [ __ ] taking drugs
anyway
in these [ __ ] hollywood scenes
[ __ ]
kind of degenerates
yeah so okay so anyway um the the thing
about it was that
since william peter blatty and william
friedkin didn't want anything to do with
this movie so they got this playwright
named william goodheart and he came in
and wrote the script and his idea which
i'm arguing from the outset probably not
a terrible idea
he wanted to
base it kind of around the original like
a priest
who was actually the original like the
real guy that was the original
inspiration for father marin in the
original book which like i said not a
terrible so
more metaphysical kind of direction so
they bring john borman in obviously who
also did zardoz and deliverance and
uh excalibur and all that
and uh he comes in and his whole thing
and i'm not sure this is how because
honestly this is barely a horror movie
it's not really scary
um
i don't know i guess it's a horror movie
but i guess not but the thing about it
is that
john borman thought the original movie
was quote unquote repulsive
and basically his idea was he's like
look i have daughters and i feel like
the first movie was all about abusing
children like for the sake of
entertainment pretty much
so the second movie he's like i thought
it would be more interesting to go in a
positive uplifting direction
so he was the one that kind of went with
the idea of going in a more metaphysical
route where
the demon was like attracted more to
like good people yeah
where
and you could argue because i know that
this movie does have its defenders uh
probably its most famous one being
martin scorsese
uh who
thought this one was kind of like oh
like a you know job type of story but to
be honest with you i think it's scarier
okay the original exorcist was scary
because one the even though the demon
like supposedly said it was pazuzu even
though i don't think they even say the
name pazuzu in the first one uh although
they do in the book
even though the demon says it's that
it's clearly like satan you know what i
mean it's like the big s i think they
did put a safe pazuzu in the book they
did say it in the book they didn't say
it in the first movie i think they did
say in the movie i don't think they said
it in the first thought in the book they
did i thought when they dug it up
when they dug that statue up i thought
that in the background or something like
the the the people singing they said
pazuzu oh maybe but i'm just saying it
wasn't really like exposited
and then i think uh i think father maron
said something about
the statue of azuzu i think you think he
said that i think it was mentioned but
it does never mentioned in the
second part when there's a uh
exorcism going on i don't think was ever
mentioned there no yeah i mean like i
said i don't really remember it being
mentioned in the movie although it was
mentioned in the book i don't think
marin knew it was pazuzu yeah
so but like i said the the implication
in the first movie was that it wasn't
pazuzu it was just like
satan but he was just kind of masking
himself as that like just just to [ __ ]
with marin specifically yeah because
he'd found that relic or what i mean
that's how i took it
so one it was the big s which you know
is really scary satan second thing was
that there was no reason why reagan was
possessed it was random which is way
scarier so i think if you're going in a
direction i'm not saying it can't be
done but i think if you're going in a
direction that the second one tried to
go in saying oh there's a reason oh by
the way it's not satan it is actually
pazuzu which kind of like
lowers the rank of the evil somewhat to
just this one specific assyrian demon no
he didn't think it was mentioned
no i i don't think it was he thought it
was no i'm pretty sure it's hot i knew
about it
well maybe you read the book no i never
work or you know just it's been filtered
through so much media yeah because it
was mentioned in the book okay just i'm
pretty sure no one said that name in the
movie in the first movie but in the
second movie it really makes up for it
because i always called that thing
pazuzu i didn't i thought it was
mentioned in the movie no okay no but
like i said it the movie seeped so much
into the cultural consciousness and the
book did as well i'm just imagining so
it's easy to see that you think that i'm
sure it's kind of like that mandela
effect thing where you think that it was
mentioned in the movie i'm 99 sure it
was not mentioned in the movie um though
it wasn't the book because i did read
the book i have it somewhere actually
dermot says i saw this in the cinema age
11 with my 10 year old cousin on our own
yep it was the 70s would never happen
today
didn't like
didn't like it but have grown to like it
is it so bad it's good
yeah
i remember [ __ ]
my
14 year old babysitter 13 or 14 year old
babysitter taking me to see r-rated
movies in the matinee
in the 70s it didn't matter
they just
it was horror movies
yeah
like i remember seeing amityville horror
i think it was andyville or i saw the
trailer i wanted to sometimes i did see
you know the evil she took me to see
that yeah what year was that 1980 maybe
or 79 i think it was 79.79
so i'd have been about 11 or 12. i
reviewed that a while back yeah
yeah
not even 10. that was 10. yeah
okay
but uh but yeah so the thing about it is
that i kind of just feel like it makes
it that's why i'm saying it's barely a
horror movie because it makes it a lot
less scary that you're demoting the
demon
to some minor
assyrian demon that's just kind of like
a locust demon that targets and and also
that it targets people like specific
people people that have psychic healing
powers
so they're implying that reagan had that
but that's never been brought up
and it's only barely brought up in the
movie in exorcist two
when she's at this you know hospital or
whatever she's at and she makes that
little autistic girl talk that odd
little autistic girl is played by dana
plato actually yeah
of all things well yeah well i was like
looking at her i'm like that is dana
plato she looks exactly the same as a
little kid as she looked when she was
older
like on different strokes she died very
unsadly yeah she became a rock head but
yeah rockhead porn star it's just funny
that i recognized her immediately well
it's funny because the other night i was
watching the rifftrax version of uh a
talking cat
which is not as awesome as it sounds
uh although eric roberts did do the
voice of the cat um but
the guy that was in it i'm looking at
him going
that dude is a former child star who the
[ __ ] is it is it and i couldn't remember
his name but i was like no family affair
family affair
and uh tom looked it up and he's like
yeah it was johnny whittaker from a
family affair did not age well uh no and
he was my age in that movie and man i
was just like dude i felt bad for him
he looked like a 70 year old little fat
man
that was a plus that was a terrible
terrible terrible movie wow
i just i'm even rip tracks could barely
save it yeah i was like well at least i
had a cute kitty in it poor kitty whose
name was squeaky maybe i'll talk more
about that on the [ __ ] side track
show cause yeah i got some thoughts
about that [ __ ] movie but uh but yeah
so
max von sydow did come did come back but
he is also barely in it he's only in
like a couple flashback scenes
and they had to get a stand in when they
do the flashback
uh for linda blair because like i said
she wouldn't wear the the makeup
uh you know you can't say a blamer to be
honest with you well honestly uh well
what happened to her on the first film i
don't know if you know this but
um
they didn't use a stunt double on some
of the scenes in the first movie when
they probably should have because like i
said she was only like 12.
so they had her like you know the scene
where she's like flopping back and forth
in bed like that that was her and they
had her in a harness
and it actually i think it broke her
spine damn uh so she and she actually
subsequently had scoliosis
from that
um so you know and uh another thing too
i i feel so bad for linda blair because
she signed on to this whole movie i mean
she's just a kid she was only 17.
she signed onto this movie because
richard burton was in it and like like
she said the original version of the
script was actually really good but it
got subsequently rewritten and nobody
really knew what was going on from day
to day it seemed like i mean just from
like listening to people that worked on
it
but uh so she probably thought okay well
i'm not doing the demon makeup so they
didn't make her do that but one thing
they did make her do you know those
scenes where she's up on the roof of
that building yeah and like
she did that are we walking on that
skyscraper
yeah yeah
um if you haven't seen the movie there's
a couple scenes like she has this
apartment like a penthouse apartment
that's actually a real building it's on
fifth avenue it's where the warner
brothers uh offices were at the time
and they didn't hire a stunt double no
uh no safety equipment no nothing did
you just understand it on the left yes
and they filmed it crazy sons of [ __ ]
i'd have been like
absolutely not i mean i am i'm really
afraid of heights yeah um but yeah the
shots where you look
holy [ __ ]
and she's like standing there like right
on the edge like in her bare feet yeah i
don't even think they had a harness or
anything
idiots i'd have been like
you know what it's like what if she'd
just been like uh you know she'd be
[ __ ] dead holy crap you think that
would put a man [ __ ]
that'd be the end of somebody's career
today if they tried that [ __ ]
well that was i mean
and especially she was like a minor i
mean she's under 18. i mean you would so
get arrested for that nowadays and
rightfully so well going back to what i
said before 17 at that time in the 70s
guys in vietnam at 17 16. fighting the
war
thinking just another time i mean yeah
you had 17 year old boys out in vietnam
first i know well i'm just saying it's
just you know people can say all they
want but it's like i i don't really want
to go back to a time where life was that
cheap you know what i'm saying she's
just kind of like ah there's lots of
those that's all right and it's like
we'll just get another one but weren't
expected to live very long anyway and
they [ __ ] lived at a very fast pace
took a lot of drugs [ __ ] a lot of
alcohol they were [ __ ] drinking and
[ __ ] smoking and dropping acid by
[ __ ] 14 15.
they lived fast
yeah louie points out already you were
used up a lot of them where they thought
you were
louis points out ellen burstin was also
hurt in the first movie yeah she was uh
the one scene where she gets thrown
across the the room
uh you know and like hits the she hits
like a dresser or something like that
where reagan throws her across the room
yeah she got all [ __ ] up in that too
so yeah william friedkin
um
his methods were also quite questionable
but
i guess you can justify it a little bit
more because at least the movie was
awesome yeah this one
not so much the script was originally
good yeah well and they said what ended
up happening was that they kept
rewriting it i mean according to linda
blair and according to a couple of other
people that were on the set
they were like um they just kept coming
up with all these new ideas about all
this metaphysical stuff and just putting
that in and they were just kind of like
putting it in there so it's like no one
she kind of implied that no one really
knew what was going on and she's like as
the shoot went on uh richard burton who
you know was another one of those kind
of legendary drunks
um they said he was okay like you know
for the first
portion of the shooting but then after a
while he kind of started showing up
drunk um nobody like i said nobody
really knew what was going on so we had
to keep so they had to make cue cards
for the lines because it's just oh we
just added this so you have to kind of
and there are actually a few scenes in
the movie where richard burton appears
to talk directly to the camera yeah
right um
so
i guess
so i guess it just seems like i don't
know like i said i there are a couple of
good ideas in here i don't necessarily
mind i don't love it okay um i
okay what i will say is if the ideas in
this movie had been presented in a
context that didn't have anything to do
with the original exorcist
then i think people would be a lot more
for forgiving you know what i'm saying
but i think that because the original
exorcist was such a masterpiece
i mean pretty much any sequel you made
was going to be a disappointment let's
not you know let's not
say
anything about that because that movie
was just so good it's like how the [ __ ]
are you gonna follow that how are you
gonna make something just as good or
better it's just not gonna work out and
so i respect that they wanted to do
something different and i don't
necessarily in you know in isolation
have a problem with
the idea that they went with that
there's this specific demon that goes
after people with this specific psychic
power and that his he goes around in
plagues of locusts
and all this other kind of stuff like i
said like a job type of story like
martin scorsese
perceives it as i don't have a problem
with that
in isolation i just don't think they
should have tried to
tie it back to the exorcist story
because not only is the movie not that
great by itself but it also kind of
shits on the first movie
you know what i'm saying like
retroactively yeah if you think about it
too much right i uh
i gotta say that
it's not as bad as i thought it was
gonna be
it would i i was entertained it tried to
to do a bunch of stuff and show you a
bunch of [ __ ] it was trying to keep you
entertained through the whole thing
it had
good stars in it
the acting was good enough
yeah the acting was fine the acting was
fun cool scenes where [ __ ]
dude falls on the spikes and wakes up
uh there's a lot of good ideas in it it
is
kind of a mess
yeah some of this is kind of good for
dino de laurentiis
studios it
it's kind of doing what a lot of italian
movies do they just give you some more
oh you like that well here's more here's
some more and here's some more and they
got a director who is
i think he's a good director but he's uh
uh he's out there you know with zardoz
and [ __ ]
yeah and like i said that's not i'm not
[ __ ] on the dude because john borman
was an ambitious
story yeah they added too much probably
they said the original script was real
good probably just stuck with the
original script probably would have been
remembered better they they're just
probably just trying to pack a bunch of
stuff in it just to wow the audiences
that's probably what it was and i mean i
guess it was the 70s and like i said it
seemed like they wanted to go in a more
metaphysical direction so they wanted to
tie in a sort of
yeah
parapsychology
thing with the whole louise fletcher uh
you know with her invention of the
synchronizer which
essentially allows you to like put a
thing on your head and look into a
flashing light and have another person
do that on the other side of the table
and you can like go into their memories
somehow yeah
he invented he invented some [ __ ]
paranormal some parapsychological tools
for paranormal investigations
and you know would have wowed the
audience at the time i mean they kind of
did the same thing with the entity where
the idea they're going to freeze a damn
poltergeist you know inventing
technology just to [ __ ] show you some
questions
what the [ __ ] were they smoking when
they thought of like freeze that was the
end that was the enemy we need to see
that again i really yeah i've been
wanting to rewatch that i actually
really like that movie except for the
end which is like dumb as [ __ ] but the
rest of it's good hey man it's like an
80s action flick
we're gonna catch this [ __ ] yeah it
was like ghostbusters but it wasn't
supposed to be a comedy yeah
and then
um another uh
part three
actually kind of was
was a good standalone one two and three
are much better than what two and three
are better than i remembered them or
would have thought
exorcist three
exodus three is closer that's an
exorcist one in tone honestly that's
what you do if you actually want to make
a quote-unquote sequel that does have
some ties to the first one
but
doesn't um but tries to but does
something different with it and i think
successfully does something different
with it
because i think the problem with the
second one other than it having
too many goofy ass ideas uh that were
kind of crammed in there and also
i kind of feel like there weren't really
any
it wasn't really scary and there weren't
really any stakes
what exactly was
pazuzu's end game like what was he
trying to do a bunch of locusts and
[ __ ] attack good people and i guess
eat your crops i guess and and it seemed
like pizzuzi was really easy to defeat
so he didn't really seem like much of an
adversary whereas
yeah but like in the first one i mean
we're dealing with like satan
this one reminded me a lot more of
[ __ ] the uh um
uh
the omen
the tongue you have the almond omen two
and open three kind of [ __ ] yeah it
was all over the place and
i like those too i gotta say that you
know
the sequels are not as bad as i thought
they were gonna be
for for the exorcist and even amityville
[ __ ] ebonyville 2 was good
when they go back to the defeos and they
go yeah
i thought that was good i didn't see
three that was a 3d one it's probably
terrible but then we saw four and didn't
that wouldn't that involve the cat
that was the one that we saw at rifftrax
live wasn't it is that four was that the
one about the possessed lamp that didn't
have anything to do with it didn't have
anything to do with anything yeah it
wasn't even in the same house
[ __ ] was [ __ ] terrible i actually
wouldn't mind seeing
the amityville 3 again well we i was
thinking about last night because i said
oh i kind of want to watch amityville 2
but then i was like oh wait i think we
just watched that not too long ago it's
just
i've seen amityville 3 but it was a long
time so retelling the defeo murders and
pretty accurate pretty close to the kids
that's right yeah we did watch that i
think we watched it when
maybe when we were doing a show about it
in a way it may have been better than
one because i have one and i like it but
if you go back and watch it there's not
a whole lot to amityville one
well but that's in a way that's kind of
its charm is that i mean it kind of like
it's nowadays if you made that they'd
call it a slow burn yeah well because
not a lot of it was big other than other
than like you know the the wild
overacting like of the priest and the
early episodes out of the which is like
five or six seasons of a haunting their
their episodes are better
than the amityville one movie in a way
yeah i mean haunting a summer win
i think it was a double episode that
[ __ ] was a bad ass on the first season
of the haunting series
[ __ ] you know
that would have been if that was in
movie form and you put that in the
theaters in the 70s that have been a
huge hit
oh yeah i'm sure because you'd have it
like a documentary yeah they'd come out
of there believe in it 100
yeah because they didn't really have my
i mean the first mockumentary well the
first
well the first found footage slash thing
was cannibal holocaust right but that
was that was 70s but not a lot of people
in the u.s saw it because you were to
take haunting a summer win off of that
[ __ ] television series re-shoot it
70s technology run it alongside
amityville one in the theaters it would
have outsold avenueville one they would
have loved it
yeah it probably would have yeah and
summerwind would have went down as a
[ __ ] haunted house much bigger than
the amityville house they'd be looking
for what if they're ever gonna make a
movie out of the summer wind thing yeah
you'd think they'd get around to i mean
maybe
they might already have i mean they've
made so many haunting and possession
movies
like cheaply that i was fascinated by
that story until uh started to
investigate more and more about it you
know when more stuff about it on the
internet came up photographs of it and
you realize there wasn't much to that
case
they did a good job on that television
program making that into something
though with the edits
yeah yeah but uh no liked it good movie
uh we gotta see the am we gotta see the
entity too now
yeah that'll that'll be one of the next
ones um but yeah somebody okay so
somebody says uh a boudicca x says james
earl jones appearance in extras 2 was
bizarre it was actually it was good
though um
you know
you got to be like pretty goddamn
dignified to turn up in the getup that
he turns up in with the big
knitted locust head on top of his actual
head
um and still kind of maintain your
dignity well i don't know did he did he
arguably maintain his dignity i'm not
really sure i guess he kind of did
that's probably how he got the job for
tulsa doom
if it probably is honestly they're like
well you're one of the few that we've
seen that they could actually wear
something that goofy and still kind of
look like you got some gravitas so you
know he was an army ranger
of course of course he could do it
but yeah so uh so the thing about it is
that
so
okay the exorcist to the heretic very
very famously even when it first came
out
um
like it was a huge like everybody was
waiting to see it like it was oh they
made it you know a sequel to the
exorcist so there's like massive lines
around the block and everything like
that
um so it actually like broke a record i
think for the time the first weekend
that it opened but then after that it
went
like straight down the [ __ ] toilet as
word of mouth started and honestly
um i can maybe think of one critic
pauline kale
who is kind of an idiot i have to say
like from her other movie opinions she
likes this one better than the original
which again that's crazy talk um but i
don't really get it but okay whatever
uh but she was basically the only one
that had anything positive to say about
it everybody else is basically like this
is the worst abortion ever put to film
um you know it just shits on the
original it's awful what they said that
when it premiered in new york city
that the audiences were just like
laughing their asses off at it
and that there's um that there's a story
that uh i think william peter blatty
tells it i'm possibly apocryphal i'm not
really sure
but he says at the first screening
somebody said like they were watching it
and somebody said oh the the execs
responsible for this movie are here and
like they
like they got chased down the street
like members of the audience like not
with pitchforks or anything but like
there's like who made this piece of [ __ ]
it's like some of them are in here and
it looks like people like red i don't
know if that's true or not but that's
like a story that he likes to tell like
at conventions and stuff
but i mean it must be said like all the
main critics of the day just thought it
was like the worst thing ever now i'm
not gonna say this is the worst thing
ever in a universe
where
coleman francis movies exist
um
there is no way that this is even
remotely
the worst movie ever made i mean i have
seen way way way worse movies than this
this is you know somewhat competently
shot the acting is fine
um you know what i mean so it's not like
the worst thing i've ever seen
um i'm not even really sure it's the
worst horror sequel i can't really say
that because i haven't seen every horror
sequel no it's not that it's not a worst
horse but
it's no way it's just it's not great
it's like the more i think about the
implications of the story and what it
says about the first one the more it
almost seems like and i don't know if
this is what he intended but it almost
seemed like john borman was trolling
or he was like making fun of the first
one i don't think so
i don't know but it almost kind of comes
across like that
in a way i think he's just trying to
give more and make it more uplifting and
make it he wanted to make it positive
yeah and then and have it more like it's
an adventure it's going happening you
know in a bunch of different locations
and a bunch of stuff happens you get to
see the demon uh more
um you see more paranormal stuff yeah
it's
he's just trying they're just trying to
give you more
yeah
they had good miniatures
you know i mean it had some decent
special effects for the time yeah i mean
the special effects are actually not bad
yeah the opening scene where they're in
the church doing the damn uh exorcism
and the girl burns herself up i thought
that was great
you know
um it was just i think the script went a
little bit off the rails it was just too
much i think
yeah i think it just had too many i mean
different tone of totally different tone
than the first one yeah
this is a standalone movie they probably
liked it
that's what i'm saying i think that it
suffered
by being i'm not saying it's you know
would have been a great movie but i
think it suffered being supposedly a
continuation of the first story yeah if
you had taken some of these ideas which
are not bad ideas in themselves
and just made your own new movie that
didn't have anything to do with that one
probably done pretty well um then it
might have done okay you know what i'm
saying i just kind of feel like it
suffers because people are comparing it
to the original exorcist is a tough act
to follow well and everybody said that
they're like look um you know you knew
warner brothers was going to want a
sequel because the original was such a
massive like had such a massive cultural
impact and made [ __ ] tons of money so
obviously they're gonna want a sequel
and you know that it's not gonna be as
good i mean how can it be as good there
are very very few movies in the world
that are as good as the exorcist so to
think that you're gonna make like more
of that but better than the first one or
even as good as the first one no way but
you know
i just i don't know it's it's an
interesting movie
the best one from this era
that was a series that was continually
good
was the omen the omen one two and three
was good
yeah i like all three of those yeah the
final conflict i liked it it had a
couple goofy moments but not real but it
was not that bad no it wasn't and um the
the blu-ray version had some stuff that
i think was cut out of the versions they
were showing on cable when we were kids
i think the ending was a little more
complicated had some more [ __ ] happened
it made more sense
that's how i because i remember some
stuff
in the versions we saw online
i remember the ending
being better
than the original ending so it must be
like a director's cut
either that or you just imagined a
better ending
no no no i saw a better ending than i
remembered from the original yeah well i
know that that's true for conan
yeah
the original ending the original ending
wasn't as good as the ending you have
now the theatrical cut
the actual cut ending wasn't that good
but if you go on right now go watch
conan it's got a different ending where
the princess comes back with him
to the uh to the thing to to the temple
and they kill to kill false doom it's
better
has a better ending
they cut that out
with a theatrical release
the first time i'd saw on that just
because the first time i saw that ending
was just a couple years ago yeah
louis says jenny but it's got to be the
worst sequel to a great movie right yeah
it's probably got to be up there
uh beezness says burdemic is the best
movie ever yeah and also burdemic
i mean burdemic exists
uh so in that universe yeah this is not
even remotely approaching of course
maybe ever everybody's settled down yeah
um there's there's some [ __ ] out there
that's just unwatchable
i mean well
i'd argue though that burdemic is
actually pretty watchable just because
it's so
incompetent um and hilarious some of the
most it looks like it was made by aliens
some of the most unwatchable movies are
steven segal's later movies
and yeah just because they're just so
boring
yeah they're very generic very very
generic very boring everybody's dubbed
in him and he was dubbed in his own
goddamn movie
and he's got [ __ ] stunt doubles to
walk up and down stairs for him so you
don't see how fat he is
he won't shoot himself in full length
only his face
just
it's [ __ ] bad you know and and
they're not it's not like a so bad it's
good thing no it's just bad bad well i
would argue that the greatest sin that a
movie can make is being boring boring
right because it's just you don't
remember anything it's like wait did i
even watch that movie because it's just
like every other movie so like i said if
you're gonna make a movie and you don't
think you can make a good one then just
make it like really really
entertainingly terrible seagal only has
two
decent movies
under siege
and what was the other one uh hard to
kill
some people will say well alpha justice
not really no not really
no even the names of them are generic i
can't even
shitkay cinema just put up another
uh another one
for steven seagal review the other day
and it was really funny but i can't even
remember what the name of the movie is
honestly has anybody made a game you
know those like poet
those poetry magnet games with like has
all the words on little magnets and you
can rearrange them and make poems has
anybody ever done that like for steven
segal movie titles because they ought to
yeah oh i forgot though he has a third
one that's
fun and that's under siege too
it's not as good as understanding
yeah but it is kind of it is fun to
watch
but that if you ask me that's the last
movie you've ever i can't stand watching
any of his movies last movie because
every time i look at him i just want to
punch the reason why under siege 2 is so
good
is because he's on a train with his cute
20 year old cousin and he's constantly
flirting with her for the whole time you
know he's getting ready to [ __ ] [ __ ]
his little his little cousin and [ __ ]
because he's because he can't act he's
just he just sees some [ __ ] 20 year
old chick he wants to bang and he just
comes through every [ __ ] scene he's
like yeah hey i know you're only 18 but
can i check you for breast cancer yeah
yeah yeah i'm a shiatsu master let me
check you for the lumps
jesus christ yeah he's so creepy
uh four row down points out okay i'd
agree with this some of the howling
sequels are way worse than this oh yeah
oh yeah and honestly the howling is
really really good i don't it's not a
masterpiece or anything but it's like a
really really good werewolf movie uh the
second one i try i watched the second
one
on cable back in the day and i remember
it being okay but i tried to watch it
again recently it's unwatchable i had to
turn it off after like 10 minutes the
scanners scanners was great scanners 2
is unwatchable yeah again so there are
worse sequels yeah um this one is at
least interesting for how bizarre it is
and how
i think a lot of people point that out
because the thing about it is a lot of
critics saying it's the worst sequel
stuff like that a lot of critics weren't
really like going into like the low
budget kind of horror movies so maybe
they didn't even see that or that's not
like on their radar i mean this was a
major studio production with actual real
actors in it and a real crew and had a
score the score by enia moricone again
um was which was real weird i did that
all that weird
singing and chanting that was very very
strange
yeah and um you know so there was that
whole thing uh boudicca x i hope i'm
pronouncing that right
yeah she's the [ __ ]
uh [ __ ] the english [ __ ] rebel
princess that fought off all the damn
roman oh right
that's right i know i'd seen that name
before i just never heard it said out
loud uh compare omen 2 to exorcist 2
night and day omen 2 was legit scary as
hell and the omen 2 soundtrack and sound
effects are the scariest i've ever heard
even scarier than the original omen the
whole omen series the whole omen trilogy
is yeah i like all three of those
actually yeah like i said yeah [ __ ]
hernandez got to jump in and saying the
[ __ ] alpha justice is pretty good
i barely remember out for justice i
remember oh what was the other one
[ __ ] uh excuse me
above the law i don't remember above
alpha justice was the one where he was
wearing the damn um
[ __ ] black beret right he's a [ __ ]
wait was that just one movie or that man
he's supposed to be an undercover cop
he's running around in a sleeveless
shirt with his little [ __ ] skinny
bean pole arms and his [ __ ] heart and
his [ __ ] army ranger beret he's on
duty like a [ __ ] hard ass and [ __ ]
man if [ __ ] if
if a ranger saw somebody even another
ranger wearing a [ __ ] black ranger
beret
in his civilian clothes he'd [ __ ]
knock it off his head back [ __ ] take
this [ __ ] off you [ __ ] head
you don't wear your beret and your
civilian clothes
matter of fact that's some cheesy ass
[ __ ] to do anyway leave the [ __ ]
uniform alone you you go if you get back
in the uniform somebody's gonna die
it's that kind of mentality
but uh no which is the one where he had
the black beret that one was [ __ ]
terrible
uh people liked it but it just drove
[ __ ] crazy then the other one um
the only ones that i thought was good
was hard to kill where he went where he
comes up out of the damn
coma and he's he's working he's got his
wife with him his real wife in real life
what's her name one for weird science
kelly lebron kelly lebrock yeah and it's
it's him and kelly lebrock and he spends
the whole [ __ ]
whole [ __ ] movie running running like
a [ __ ] with his arms flopping
and fighting dudes and trying to get to
the dude who nearly killed him that was
a good one because it was kind of like
terminator in a way
or or
or [ __ ] commando just like that and
and
[ __ ] under siege was good that was
the poor man's [ __ ] die hard
i liked it i'd rather just watch die
hard
yeah but tommy
tommy jones was in it [ __ ] chewing up
i know but tommy lee jones was in good
movies too yeah and he was andy and had
the other [ __ ] guy little [ __ ]
busy with his name
was
one of the boosies i think of daddy
boosie
i thought it was jake beezy
the one from [ __ ] silver bullet oh
sam i'm pretty sure yeah okay and they
just did a [ __ ] great job and [ __ ]
and that was the one where
seagal was seemed to be the most natural
you know i mean they got they got pretty
good shots of him and
they kind of portrayed him as
as a person
but [ __ ] after that he was [ __ ]
off the chain he couldn't
holly was out there out to destroy him
after that because [ __ ] nobody could
stand him because he was such a dick i
mean objection your honor i do not think
that steven seagal is an actual person
i know i think he's an alien in a fat
skin suit no he steven seagal is
something he made up
he doesn't remotely act like human being
no
no he's pretty he's a total um
100
100 fraud
100
yeah i mean he does do a little bit of
that [ __ ]
hooky ass [ __ ] jiu jitsu [ __ ]
which is not a real mark it's a martial
art but it's not a real deadly one
and he he does do that and but he can't
act and he lied about his background he
just lies about everything he's the
pathological liar and fake
i don't think danny rowland ghostface
says in my opinion exorcism films have
run their course in theaters just like
zombie films yeah i kind of i mean you
we have enough exercises in the films
for now thanks yeah there's a ton of bad
ones too i mean there's there's a lot of
good ones there's still good ones being
made i'm not saying that but it's just
kind of like it's just really
if you want to make a really good
exorcism movie or a really good zombie
movie i mean you really have your work
cut out for you because they've they've
made so many and they've made so many
from like all different angles that if
you can like think of something
original and think of something that's
going to be like mind-blowing i'd be
[ __ ] shocked yeah louis um
yeah it's a keto louis that's right good
uh mr roboto says anything with linda
blair is a masterpiece i kind of feel
bad for a little linda blair because
look she was in [ __ ] the exorcist you
know arguably not actually not even
arguably one of the best movies ever
made easily one of the best horror
movies ever made so she's in that and
then she was kind of like well i think
i'm gonna go be a veterinarian which
maybe she should have done i don't know
um because it seemed like
she ended up in and she's not she's not
a bad actress um she's cute she's a cute
girl uh you know she had you know she
had she could act decently and she just
ended up like in
some terrible stuff and i just kind of
feel like
maybe just because she had big boobs and
she was cute so everybody was like well
let's put her in these like really
[ __ ] trashy cause she always ended up
in like real trashy like women in prison
type [ __ ] that's all she could get which
you know she really would have had a
great career in porn like i said before
but
in the in that era
that was uh
once you went into porn you could never
come out
uh so she didn't do it
instead she did [ __ ]
softcore
midnight movies which was
porn but just
not really
i mean i would argue she was good in
hell night i liked that one well that
slasher movie what happened with her is
that um
the same thing happened to her is what
happened to mark hamill
she went into that role and she got cast
and that's who she was going to be she
was going to be little little possessed
reagan for the for the rest of her
[ __ ] career you just couldn't
stop that from happening
cindy happened to [ __ ] mark hamill
star wars destroyed his career that's
all he could be with luke skywalker
well that's kind of that's the
double-edged sword of having a role like
that it's like honestly in some ways you
know
actors that can't really get a role like
that would kill
to have a role where like everybody in
the [ __ ] world
knows that character and knows that face
but
if you want to do something else with
your career
good luck with that it's not gonna
happen hamlet was able to shake it back
but not on the big screen he shook it
back in the voice acting yeah and there
are some fans of his that only know him
or just [ __ ] love him from his voice
doing the joker so at least he like
found something to you know so some
people are like saying oh not his work
as the joker was much better than oh
everybody loves mark hamill's joker yeah
so you know he also made a cameo on the
new netflix uh mystery science feature
he came out he was in some bad [ __ ]
movies some of them were like almost
good but they just were [ __ ] up one of
the ones was called the guyver where he
played a [ __ ] live-action
film of a [ __ ] japanese anime about
[ __ ] bio i remember that armor you
can put it on had great [ __ ] costumes
it was like something out of power
rangers but just the script wasn't any
good
it was too
well i think it was i think it was
marketed towards like the 10 to 13
audience
10 to 14 year old audience i remember
seeing it on cable but i remember very
very little about it i mean
it must have been successful enough they
did a second one right i think they did
a second i don't think he was the guy
for in the second one though no i don't
think he was on the second one
he was in corvette summer with annie
potts yeah
yeah i don't think that did well
oh no
now uh brian was saying to watch uh
that linda blair's best movie was a
roller boogie yeah somebody's hard to
find robert h yeah robert h just said
her magnum opus roller boogie was only
two years after this yeah
i think i saw that when i was a kid
he says it's good he said it was good
but
it's just hard to break away from this
role she was typed here's another thing
is that
she was stigmatized for her role as
reagan in the first yeah that too
because they were like oh man she shoved
a cross cross up her cooch no when she
was 12 yeah she did not do that that was
suggested in the movie
yeah they don't [ __ ] well
they don't show it
exactly no she's simulating they very
skirt around it though
and
because of that i think that tarnished
her you know i mean so they're like ah
she's you know not her
which was which was weird for a seven
for the 70s because the 70s was like
artistically real permissive but there
were still a lot of straight lace people
in terms of like customers who went to
go see movies so the
evidently the
the industry was kind of afraid to put
her in any other role than something had
to do with
horror
or you know boogie nights you know
your boobs are called uh
but a lot of times movies like that
didn't do too well either you know like
[ __ ] santa dude didn't do too well
which i liked it i like santa dude it's
all right then it was kind of fun yeah
but yeah good theme song this was just
getting high token out movies watching
yeah man yeah yeah yeah man pass the
giants
that's what they were doing in the
driving
legs coming out through the open windows
and [ __ ] cars bouncing
yeah
the [ __ ] hotels of the set the
[ __ ] driving was the hotel of the
motels for the 1970s and 80s yeah i kind
of feel like even as uh freewheeling as
the 70s was
uh the exorcist was still pretty
controversial well i think the satanism
element
that yeah that too even though like i
said if you think about it if you think
about it it's a very pro-catholic movie
it's a religion movie they're positing
that god is real that satan is real and
that the priest like defeated the the
the devil yeah you know the priests are
the good guys they're the heroes 70s and
80s was weird i mean then you had the
blue lagoon thing and [ __ ] pretty
baby that was [ __ ] what's her name
brook sheilans brook shields which is b
she was basically
a kitty porn star in a way yeah
well even at the time like some people
were kind of like what
and then um
which makes you wonder like [ __ ]
michael jackson was [ __ ] into her
that's weird when you think about it
what happened to him and what he was
accused though well yeah
badass domain asked did you guys see the
exorcist tv series on fox um i actually
i didn't but i wanted to see it because
i actually heard it was uh pretty decent
you know
uh yeah and then boudicca x says
tarantino has no credit yeah because
quentin tarantino is another person that
uh has gone to bat for exorcist two uh
saying that he really likes it i don't
know if he said that he liked it more
than the original because like i said
that's that kind of seems like the thing
you would say just to be like ooh hot
take you know what i mean just cause
obviously it's wrong but um you know
what i mean uh so i don't know yeah
tarantino has no credibility he says
charles in charge was the greatest
sitcom in history yeah i kind of feel
like he's just trolling he's just
trolling he's just saying outlandish
[ __ ] like to get attention
x said about [ __ ] steven seagal where
i'll read it
i can't see it buddha x says steven
seagal worked undercover for the cia he
invented aikido he taught mma fighters
how to up kick
and most importantly he invented buffalo
wings you're [ __ ] right
you not only invent buffalo wings he ate
most of them he ate most of the buffalo
i think he probably ate like a good
portion of the world's buffalo wings
you know
judging by the girl you got to see the
asian experience commercially made with
the [ __ ] energy drink asian and then
take a bleach shower afterwards because
it'll leave you feeling really really
dirty
i'm ready to have an asian experience if
she goes inside the swimming pool with
[ __ ] with these she's like am i getting
hazard pay for this commercial
you're just sweetening the pool up for
me baby come on over here yeah he's a
[ __ ] slimeball that's nasty
it's so insane and what's funny is that
if he was self-aware that he was a slime
ball and and hammed it up it would be
kind of funny he's not
that's what well that's why he's such a
chode because he's not in on his own
joke no he's a joke to everyone but
himself yeah that's why he's a joke me
impersonating him doing that is
far less seedy than when you actually
see it you know when you actually see
him do that he well yeah because you're
aware he's serious right
like he suddenly he thinks he's being
like charming and slick and sexy and
everything and everyone else is just
like ew
i know
i think that's about it fourth drawer
down says van damme was briefly in
roller buggy well now we pretend okay
now we're really gonna have to see it so
we're gonna see roller boogie the entity
and some stuff like that mr roboto says
the 60s and 70s love making satan movies
i know there were so many honestly i
love satan movies i loved all those
[ __ ] you know i think um was the
first one was kind of like well
rosemary's baby that was like the first
big one
and then i feel like there was a lot of
uh you know somebody said race with the
devil yeah we reviewed that not too long
ago actually yeah race with the devil is
actually really good
yeah i think the satan movies died about
the 80s cocaine changed the game yeah uh
boudicca also says i'm old enough to
remember the hysteria associated with
the exorcist the first one uh you know i
was only one when the movie came out uh
people were fainting in the theaters
people were having nervous breakdowns
after seeing it yeah there there's uh
news footage i don't know if this was
just like hype from the studios back
then but i don't know if the studios
were
savvy enough to have done this
um but yeah they were interviewing
people in the thing being like man i
just couldn't take it anymore they're
like i left my friend in there by
yourself and it's like they had barf
bags and all this other kind of stuff
people talk about people being sensitive
nowadays i'm like holy crap they just go
see a movie and they're puking in the
aisles and passing out and stuff they
weren't used to seeing they'd never seen
anything like i mean yeah i mean the
exorcist
you know it's a lot for 1973. it was a
lot to to take in
uh and the people really uh weren't
ready for it i guess
i grew up you know by the time i was six
or seven i was still talking about the
movie
i was three or i was four when it came
out yeah but i just grew up knowing
about that movie people talked about it
all the time
i thought when i was a little kid i
thought it might have been something
that really had happened it took me a
while to understand that
that movies
just because it was in a movie didn't
mean it didn't happen to somebody
you know what i mean you thought every
movie was based on a true story kinda
essentially kinda until i was you know
seven or eight well no because oh a
little tall because the kids would tell
you that it was right you know what i
mean well i mean the novel was loosely
based on a quote-unquote real yeah story
so i thought that girl really existed
because the little kids thought that oh
okay you know i never saw the movie
not yet much later uh yeah buddhica said
it was unreal no movie before or since
had that much of an impact yeah i can't
really think of one not an impact a
cultural impact in that way you know
what i'm saying yeah you could say jaws
had a huge impact like just for
everybody wanting to see it nobody wants
to go swim in the ocean [ __ ] like that
but the exorcist that was like a whole
different vibe and the interesting thing
too and i had totally forgotten about
this um is that the exorcist as shocking
as it was for 1973 and how everybody
like flipped out about it uh it was also
immediately considered
a classic really i mean it was nominated
for what like 10 oscars right including
best picture which is the first horror
movie to ever have that happen and it
didn't even happen again until 1991 that
was silent to the lambs which some
people don't even think is a horror
movie it is but you know
um
and then yeah holy parish of doom says
exorcist is still shocking in my opinion
yeah parts of it uh kind of are i mean
everybody's jaded nowadays because we've
seen everything
um
so it's kind of hard to go back to that
time period like when nobody had seen
anything like this
and you know and watch it but there are
some scenes in this that
you know i guess if you didn't really
know anything about the hypo and you
watch it you'd be like holy [ __ ] you
know what i mean i think i still think
it's i think it holds up like
beautifully i think it's really i mean
you know it's a classic and like i said
you can watch young
horror movie fans
watching it for the first time that have
never seen it before and even though
it's been parodied and ripped off and
[ __ ] like that the first movie still has
like a lot
uh a lot of the same impacts that it had
back then there were two other movies
that uh me and the kids in elementary
school had a hard time [ __ ] dealing
with thinking that maybe it was real one
of them was something there was a girl
named sybil who had all these different
personalities yeah they were all talking
about it would nobody knew you know i
don't know if there was a movie or a
book yeah there was but they were and
that was hard to get my
head around there was a book and a movie
i read the book and i saw the movie oh
and it was around the same time as this
you know about i was probably about
third grade maybe
we did a show about her civil yeah they
were talking about that and [ __ ] kids
were [ __ ] pretending to be her weird
[ __ ] you know playing oh look at it
civil i have multiple personalities yeah
yeah yeah
not really knowing what that was another
one was uh [ __ ] what was that then the
other one that uh
was [ __ ] everybody up when i was a
little kid was carrie we thought that
was based on somebody that was real too
yeah girl who could burn things up and
[ __ ] throw knives with her mind and
[ __ ] like that i wish and then she had
pig blood on her
that's all we knew about it because you
all didn't know about the stephen king
book no no it didn't even they made a
movie about her
that's the way that's how a little kid
does it they made a movie about that
yeah she had pigs blood on her
i hit what she could make things move
with her mind she killed her mama oh you
know that's [ __ ] up that's all we knew
the story honestly i don't know like i
was i was a very imaginative child but i
i really don't remember ever thinking
that movies were all based on true
stories i gotta say well the first time
i would
back in those days your first time
coming in contact with the movies was
hearing about it on the play yard from
other kids who were told about it by
their older siblings
so by the time it got to you
you're being told that this is a based
on a real person
yeah okay you don't you know what i mean
it's not right because it starts off as
a story yeah being told do you buy it's
like an urban legend right right
situation being told you by another
little kid as if it's something that
actually happened
that it's uh it was there it was a
different time
louis says my mom saw the exorcist when
it came out she told me half the
audience left before it was over yeah
i could see that i mean once that sweet
little girl starts like
swearing and you know jerking off with a
cross and whatnot i can imagine people
are like oh my god won't someone think
of the children and they were like
leaving getting all offended
[Laughter]
but yeah so
so while exorcist two
i would argue it's not the worst movie
ever made
it's not an abomination under the lord
it's not worse than cancer or hitler or
whatever because i know well you know
how people like to do the [ __ ]
hyperbole all the time
yeah
i'm just sorry i thought of that
spider-man meme where it's like that
movie gave me cancer but yeah it's it's
it's not that bad
but
you know i've seen
you know hundreds of movies worse than
this one
i just
and it's interesting it's an interesting
cultural relic
in compared to the first one because i'm
just interested how it could have gone
so drastically awry
but
i don't know it's not as terrible as i
remember but it's still not that great
and i think the thing that pisses me off
the most about it is that it it
downgrades the original in retrospect
which kind of like annoys me yeah you
know what i'm saying kind of like new
star wars
well i don't even know yeah i mean maybe
that did the same thing but i kind of
feel like exorcist too like did it way
more because it was just kind of like oh
well we're downgrading the evil to like
this lame little demon
and it's not even that powerful you can
basically just like wave your arm around
and beat it it's like you know if you
have the special psychic powers which oh
by the way we never mentioned before
it's just i don't know it seemed like
they were retconning
some [ __ ] and
you know it just seemed like a mess is
what it seemed like it's still worth
watching
uh just for how goofy it is and there
are some interesting ideas in there
but you can tell that it was a very
troubled production
you know you can tell
uh yeah so i guess that'll do it for
today's show be sure to come by tomorrow
evening for our regular episode at 5 p.m
we're going to be talking about
the
pennsylvania torso murders which
everybody's heard of the cleveland torso
murders but hardly anybody has heard of
these even though they might be related
so we're going to be talking about that
tomorrow night so thanks everybody for
dropping by and talking about exorcist 2
with us and we will see you guys
tomorrow